this building in Leipzig houses the
al-rahman mosque Germany's Intelligence
Service says many of the worshippers
support a militant brand of Islam known
as salafism the Imam Hasan daba views
this as the only true form of Islam we
don't want children who are lazy and who
sit at home on Facebook until three
o'clock in the morning and then sleep
until noon no we want children who learn
to practice religion and have good
characters character the Imam does not
usually allow anyone to film in the
mosque he does so today on condition
that no faces are shown he accuses the
international community of double
standards when it comes to Islamic state
he says they have failed to act against
the real criminal Syrian President
Bashar al-assad as you are Julian gate
okay one who goes to Syria and fight is
labeled a terrorist and must be punished
but what about the people in Syria were
fighting for Assad those who leave
Germany and fight for the other side the
Yazidis and the Kurds were also fighting
there they're all fighting details and
Randy Jensen he says many young ayer's
fighters from Germany think the world
has failed to protect people in Syria
they see is is taking on this role as
good bunch of on in and directly there
are some who joined because they're
motivated and because they say the whole
world has turned a blind eye they can
see that women are being raped and
children are being butchered and people
are being killed and they want to
protect these people ich ich mesh there
are these alotta [ __ ] ssin Germany's
Intelligence Service says there is no
evidence that men from this mosque are
fighting in Syria representatives of the
Lutheran Church have the doubts
Guardians over in summer I had a query
from a head teacher in Leipzig because a
young man who belongs to this community
is pressuring his family Massey photo
book sets funds are not awful and he is
demanding his mother live in accordance
with Salafist principles and his sisters
to addition mostly
mr. he is clearly in the process of
becoming radicalized aandavan bada bhai
sister Gauri collision Amanda bar from
Leipzig is controversial in Germany his
critics say his teachings encourage
young people to become radical